we miss you won't next time our blasters
are useless against him hey let's make
the baby do the magic hands come on baby
do the magic hand thing
I'm out of ideas welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is gonna be my new
video for the Mandalorians season two
Giancarlo Esposito Moff gideon himself
was at the TCAs recently and talked
about what's going on during season two
revealed a whole bunch of plot details
so we'll do a top 10 WTF breakdown if
you're new to my channel I'll be doing
Mandalorian bonus videos until season 2
episodes get here later this year the
reason almost done filming all the
season 2 episodes they've been filming
for a long time now if you guys didn't
realize so obviously careful for
spoilers for everything from season 1 if
you haven't watched the season 1
episodes yet but Giancarlo Esposito
talked about everything from having
flashbacks to the Great Purge with the
Mandalorian character because he was on
Mandalore during all that the dark saber
he talked about his evil machinations
and his plans for the baby Yoda
character he didn't call himself evil
though no great villain thinks of
themselves as evil but starting with
number 10 we have to address George
Lucas on set so Jon Favreau was recently
filming I believe was episode 5 for
episode 6 of the Mandalorian George
Lucas visited the set again just like he
did during season 1 to see what they're
up to this time because there's no great
secret about the baby Yoda character he
actually took a picture of George Lucas
holding him so Papa bless there's all
these classic pictures of George Lucas
with the Yoda puppet he's so protective
of it he's basically Yoda's father
within the context of making Star Wars
so think of him as the grandfather or
the Godfather at least of baby Yoda a
lot of people have also asked if George
Lucas visiting the set so much and the
mandalorian blowing up so big if George
Lucas would ever come back to direct in
episode of the Mandalorian I don't know
if he would ever direct a full episode
because he's effectively in retirement
but there's always the possibility that
George Lucas could direct some scenes
during the mandalorian I don't know if
he would ever want to do it a full
episode but if jon favreau ever reveals
any details like that of course i'll
include it in one of my videos steven
spielberg for instance directed some of
the scenes during the final fight
between Anakin Skywalker and obi-wan
during Star Wars Episode three so George
Lucas might do something like that with
the Mandalorian or one of the other
Disney Plus series they'll finish
filming all the season 2 episodes in the
next couple of weeks by the end
February basically so we'll probably get
the first big teaser trailer for the
mandalorian season - by the spring but
number 9 Giancarlo Esposito was at the
TCA is this past week he did this big
interview talking about all these season
two mandalorian details so of course
everyone was asking him what is your
plan for baby Yoda what is mob Gideon
want with him what's going on with the
dark saber are you gonna have any
flashbacks with the Mandalorian
character the answers that he gave is
kind of circuitous so I'm just gonna
paraphrase him a little bit he says with
someone who is advanced in a certain way
you could want to be their best friend
or you could want to co-opt what's
inside them to figure out how to make
all of us a little better at humanity so
it's that power and control of a moth
leader who is trying to put the universe
back together he's exaggerating a little
bit when he talks about universe
obviously we're just talking about the
one galaxy that most of the Star Wars
stories take place in he then references
the characters history and why he knows
all these things why he knows about baby
Yoda why he understands him in a way
that the Mandalorian character doesn't
yet like you might think that you know
how important he is but you don't
I assure you during that big scene in
Episode eight so number eight he just
confirms a couple big plot teasers and
things that they set up during season
one in certain scenes but never fully
answered before the finale a lot of
hanging plot threads they had to address
during season two when is the mysterious
doctor purging in his ties to the
cloning facility on Kamino - they're
sampling of baby Yoda's DNA in that bio
bed in Episode three before the mando
came back to save him and then three the
fact that Moff Gideon still wants baby
Yoda alive in the finale like the
bumbling scout trooper said played by
Adam pally and Jason Sudeikis most
people would just remember them as the
baby Yoda punchers that big twist in the
finale though it was kind of interesting
because during episode 3 when the mando
was rescuing baby Yoda doctor purging
claimed that he's the only reason that
he's still alive
he'd be dead if it weren't for me I've
been trying to save him why then was it
so important that Moff Gideon get baby
Yoda back alive in the finale it
probably has something to do with the
viability of the cloning process but
I'll talk about that in a second number
seven the really funny thing though the
Adam pally told about this scene when
they were filming it with the baby Yoda
character he said in the very first take
he punched baby Yoda so hard that jon
favreau on set called cut walked over to
him very
and said you know I know we have to do
this scene you're supposed to punch the
puppet there but I just want to let you
know that that puppet cost five million
dollars just want to let you know that
before we start doing more takes most
people watching that scene weren't
thinking about that they're just really
upset that he was punching baby Yoda how
dare you punch baby Yoda but in real
life that tiny little puppet that they
use for baby Oda really did cost five
million dollars so Jon Favreau was just
telling him please don't break the prop
because it'll cost a ton of money to
make another one but number six all the
things that Giancarlo Esposito is saying
just confirms a lot of our suspicions
that not only does he want to use baby
Otis DNA in cloning techniques to create
an army of super clones that are force
sensitive like an army of clone
inquisitors he also wants to continue
using baby Yoda himself twisting him to
his purpose the same way that the
Emperor wanted to use Anakin Skywalker
and then tried to use Luke Skywalker and
even Rey during the new trilogy the
reason why everyone is so hot on clones
after the events of the original trilogy
is that by the time of a new hope most
of the clone army had died off there was
still some clones running around in
Commander Cody for instance is still
kind of left in this ambiguous state you
don't know if he's alive if he's dead so
presumably he's still running around the
galaxy somewhere but during the course
of the original trilogy and then even
through the events of the new trilogy
most of the troops you see walking are
the stormtroopers the first-order
troopers and then the Rebs it's troopers
are all made up of normal people now
they get those people from different
places but after the events of the
original trilogy you have a lot of
people wanting to go back to using
clones for their armies just because
they're so much easier to program in
control so Moff Gideon just wants a very
controllable army of force-sensitive
warriors that he can send around the
galaxy they kind of did that during the
Clone Wars animated series where Emperor
Palpatine was trying to steal the
force-sensitive children of Jedi and
twist them to the dark side to raise
them to be inquisitors so number five
when Moff Gideon says he's quote-unquote
putting the galaxy or the universe back
together after the fall of the empire
he's on the same kind of Bend that Darth
Vader was on I have a very strong idea
of what order looks like and I'm gonna
bring my order to the chaos that is the
galaxy right now and even though we only
got a glimpse of the New Republic during
the course of season one remember
during episode six there on the prison
ship that belongs to the New Republic
Matt Lanter who was the voice of Anakin
Skywalker on Clone Wars played that
trooper right now while this is all
going on in the Mandalorian you have
Leia and the other rebellion leaders
trying to form the new Republic it's
still in its very early stages and you
have a slightly older Luke Skywalker
spending most of his time flying around
the galaxy trying to stamp out the
remnants of the Empire and the new
warlords that rose up in their absence
people like Moff Gideon all over the
galaxy
remember the Mandalorian series takes
place in a relatively small sector of
the galaxy so even though Moff Gideon
seems like a really big figure you're
really only talking about a small piece
of this giant puzzle which is number
four the main reason why Luke Skywalker
isn't anywhere near this stuff boy you
haven't seen him on the series yet
mostly because they don't want to recast
an adult Luke Skywalker right now but
within the logic of the story Luke is so
busy on the other side of the galaxy and
it's a huge galaxy he just hasn't heard
anything about a baby Yoda running
around forced choking people yet there's
nothing in any of the story that they've
created for the Star Wars Expanded
Universe the new expanded universe that
says anything about Luke Skywalker's
contact with the baby Yoda character not
because they don't want us to know just
because they literally have not written
that story yet and Jon Favreau was so
secretive about the baby Yoda character
when they created it for the Mandalorian
series number three Giancarlo Esposito
also talked about the history of the
dark saber because it was a really big
deal that he got to use it during the
finale he said that he didn't realize
that he was gonna get to use it till
right before they filmed that scene but
he confirmed where he acquired it when
he acquired it it was on Mandalore
during the great purge which is also
when he learned everything about these
main characters he says all these things
about their backstories revealing that
he knows a lot of their secrets they
don't realize what's going on till the
Mandalorian remembers that he was on
Mandalore before the great purge is an
imperial security bureau officer
so Giancarlo Esposito just clarified
that it's not that he knows everything
about everyone it's just that he has
access to the Mandalorians database and
informational archives that he collected
during that period of the great purge
that's also when he came into possession
of the dark saber youth remember that
the branch of the military that he
belonged to is mostly tasked with in
security and information gathering
literally combing through other people's
databases so that's what he would have
done when they started occupying
Mandalore so cut to present-day he just
has access to all these informational
archives and was able to research these
people when they found out who it was
stole baby Yoda Oh was a Mandalorian
which Mandalorian okay let's look him up
in the computer in reality the
Mandalorian grief carga cardoon aren't
people that he would normally care about
like he wasn't tracking them until they
got involved with baby Yoda number two a
really good example of what Moff Gideon
would have been doing was during rogue
one when they go to scare up to steal
the Death Star plans the facility is an
ASB facility where Moff Gideon would
have had regular access where they store
a lot of their secret information
remember one of the secret plans they
find while they're looking for the Death
Star plans is project black saber just
to be clear black saber isn't the same
thing as the dark saber black saber was
a secret project that the emperor
commissioned but was meant to be part of
a future movie plot that never panned
out so maybe they'll decide to bring
back that quote unquote black saber
Easter egg in a future Disney Plus
series but number one the other big
characters so there's a lot of talk of
Sabine Wren Bokke tan Crees Tamira
Morrison coming back as one of the
clones or Commander Cody he just happens
to be the biggest clone maybe even as so
kitano and even I didn't versio the
character played by jayna gank of art
during the battlefront series because
she was asked recently to on Twitter
like are you coming back for this so all
these people that have played characters
during the clone wars during Star Wars
rebels are all keen to come back and
start during the series but in terms of
how many of them I think that they'll
actually include just remember the
amount of fanservice that they did
during season one so episode five
probably the most fanservice each
episode of the Mandalorian season one
they go to Tatooine they do all the
original trilogy and prequel shout outs
she has the high ground it's no use
they tease Boba Fett but they never
really answer that of course they're
gonna follow up on that during season
two but just expect that level of
fanservice during season two so maybe a
couple episodes maybe one or two
characters from some of those original
series in anybody they don't include
during season to remember the
Mandalorian will probably run for at
least four or five seasons in there the
other Disney Plus series like the
obi-wan series now there's even a
rumored Knights of the Old Republic
Disney Plus series even though that'd be
sent
thousands of years in the past and be a
completely different group of characters
well let me know in the comments what
kind of flashbacks do you want to see
during season 2 do you want to see some
baby Yoda flashbacks I don't think
they'll explain everything about his
character but maybe a couple things
that'll give you an idea for where he
came from and just a reminder that the
Clone Wars season 7 episodes are gonna
start February 17th but congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
star wars video tevye smolka please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details everyone click
here for all my Mandalorian season 2
episodes and videos and click here to
watch Azra miller's flash crossover with
grant gustin's flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
[Music]
you